okay now to an A-list party to end all
ayla's parties first a little backstory
Michael Rubin is the CEO of Fanatics a
world's leading provider of licensed
sports merchandise now over the weekend
at his house in the Hamptons he had an
absolutely epic July 4th part yeah the
dress code was all white everything in
the stars came out to play apparently
there were 350 guests in attendance so
we had JLo and Ben were there the
Beavers Tom Brady Jay-Z was there yeah
Lori Hardy shared the most epic Tick
Tock complete with Haley Bieber Kendall
Jenner and Kim Kardashian so it would
probably be faster to say who wasn't
there more guessing good Tiffany haddish
Kevin Hart and DJ Khaled there were also
performances by Jack Harlow Usher and
Neo I mean this is the party do you
remember P Diddy used to throw those
walls yeah I think that's where he got
the idea but I feel like this is a party
for hookups right I mean I'm thinking
specifically Kim Kardashian and Tom
Brady I mean
they looked amazing I just wish I was
invited to the party well you should
have brought I mean we probably could
have crashed it if you would swore all
white invite me next time